dai siamo arrivati assieme arrivati al
giorno siamo arrivati al giorno in cui
devo fare questa cosa va bene come posso
iniziare questo video che penso sia uno
dei più facili che abbia mai fatto basta
essere me stesso se avete visto il video
dove spiego quante volte ho fatto
l'esame della patente capite molto di
che cosa sto parlando quindi andate
recuperati col dito se non avete visto
ma ben sintetizza re io sono stato
bocciato alla teoria della patente sette
volte sette
tra non molto dovrà rifare l'esame della
patente quindi te io adesso mi sto
riscrivendo ok quindi lo farò tra un
paio di mesi probabilmente non mi
proveranno mai perché veramente ripeto
dalla vita che non faccio quiz quindi
adesso per la prima volta dopo secoli ci
sta riprovando vi vediamo cosa esce
fuori esavalente b 2019 eventi ad esso
come se la 40 domande due per ogni
argomento primaria
ok siamo già partiti va bene più di
questo tipo un test di quelli che ci
saranno queste ci fossimo esame ok bene
in un centro abitato se si vede un
pallone rotolare sulla carreggiata già
diminuire subito la velocità certo mica
aumentiamo citai schiaccia bilan subito
alla citate ero next 40 domande così
ragazzi lo fate 7 volle un totale di 30
per sé se milito 22 110 minuti della mia
vita
più soldi più tempo buttati nel cesso le
macchine agricole possono essere a volte
o a cingoli a me interessa tantissimo a
me lorenzo stoney mi interessa proprio
un sacco sapere se le macchine agricole
sono a ruote o a cingoli perché io
voglio proprio comprarmi un cazzo di
trattore comunque a ruote a cingoli
macchina agricola che io sappia se ci
sono le macchine di una cingoli perché a
mente che cosa venne però si disegna
raffigurato indica la fine del divieto
di sorpasso per veicoli merci di massa a
pieno carico superiore a 3,5 tonnellate
cosa teoricamente sì perché senza la
sbarra sarebbe un divieto di sorpasso
per veicoli merci di ma su questa quindi
la sbarra unica fini qui si vero sono
tutte vere dovremo mettere un falso del
suo brand per logica questa è falsa
quando si circola nelle zone a velocità
inferiori a 30 chilometri non è
obbligatorio l'uso del cane del casco fe
del calco stavo dicendo del cacco vedono
in testa falso certo deve usarlo si usa
sempre il casco video educativo sel un
infortunato della strada è entrato un
corpo estraneo in un occhio quindi se
andate in giro e per caso una lontra vi
entra nell'occhio
bisogna sempre cercare comunque di
toglierlo falso perché se tu utenti di
toglierli questa londra che gli è
entrata nell'occhio potresti tirare
fuori una parte di cervello quindi devi
lasciarla e aspettare che i medici
facciano loro ok
lasciala falso in caso di pioggia
occorre passare velocemente sulle
pozzanghere per evitare rimanere
impantanati che ios ha poi magari
sbaglio poi magari sbaglio ma che io
sappia se tu passi velocemente sulle
pozzanghere si attiva il fenomeno
dell'acquaplaning che quella roba che la
macchina rimane un pelo a galla e quindi
papa è tipo da zac tipo marcon share
quindi no non lo devi fare teoricamente
quindi in falso senza contare il fatto
che se ci sono poveri cristiani che
attraversano la strada del sul
marciapiede gli schizzi che è un piacere
cosa che ovviamente a tutti quanti nella
vita è successo almeno una volta il
pannello integrativo figura può essere
abbinato al segnale di divieto quindi
divieto di passare di qua certo gli
autobus è certo ovvio è che non lo fai
bisogna rapinato preannuncia che non è
consentito svoltare a destra è vero
perché se c'è questo qua ha l'obbligo di
svoltare a sinistra non puoi svoltare a
destra quindi obbligato ad un'attività
vero nell'incrocio ha presentato nella
figura dei col n
dopo essersi portato al centro
dell'incrocio della tenda del transito
dei veicoli
r è appeso n entra quasi ferma fa
passare
r e a zero quindi vero che ho
teoricamente sulle precedenze non sono
male la brocca annata sicuro proprio
quando giunti in prossimità
dell'incrocio ci accolliamo io ho
sbagliato la corsia di preselezione non
dobbiamo arrestare bruscamente per
evitare tamponamenti code beh certo la
consegna di preselezione e quella dove
tu ti infili quando poi devi svoltare
adesso a sinistra però vabbè non puoi
svoltare se ci sei già dentro c'è
dipenda che ne so dunque sì vero 11 o
finalmente una domanda che sempre
fantastico la patente di categoria a
attenzione attenzione come stiamo
facendo quiz patente b al cuore
insomma a me che cazzo me ne frega da
patente a abilità guidare i motocicli
cilindrata superiore a 50 cc io so cosa
significa cubi di rubik
anche se
una velocità superiore a 45 km orari fin
qua secondo me è giusto quando c'è la
anche se teoricamente false sono piccole
chicche poi magari mi sbaglio ripeto
questa proprio non lo so però anche se
sì come la velocità superiore 45 di
doveva di no deduco che non sia così da
come posta la domanda poi magari mi
sbaglio 12 secondo le norme di
precedenza all'incrocio abilità in
vigore ti dico o transita per ultimo
vediamo allora transitano prima serious
troppo perché non hanno la il segnale di
precedenza poi transita b
e poi io certo quindi se in un centro
abitato quando un pedone fuori dalle
strisce di attraversamento non accenna a
darci la precedenza è necessario della
velocità fino a fermarsi tempestivamente
se occorre certo investiamo l'ho
inventato lo espongano segna raffigurato
per a pisa di svoltare a destra per via
gemona al primo incrocio vediamo
se questa è la destra fino a prova
contraria
quindi se la distanza di sicurezza è una
di senza fissa falso segna raffigurato
impone di mantenere una distanza di
sicurezza di almeno 80 metri falso
perché 80 metri tu non lo vedi mancano
segnali semafori figura segnala un
ascensore pubblico certe come no e come
non ci sono i segnalatori negli
ascensori ma sempre la distanza di
sicurezza deve essere mantenuta per
evitare lo scontro laterale l'acqua dio
quando superi una persona devi mantenere
una certa distanza che sono certo senso
se c'è una macchina dietro e sta un po
distanza no un casino per i file la
portiera quindi c'è anche quella
distanza di sicurezza ma dove stai
parlando alla distanza di sicurezza
standard quindi quella che ci è data
quindi falso è sempre vietato effettuare
la notizia passa a destra falso in
alcuni casi puoi farlo solo in alcuni
casi chi fosse il tipo sta svoltando a
sinistra è la strada è a senso unico non
so se va beh comunque sentito stata
tutta puoi farlo ogni tanto in presenza
di tratti saleh cacciati opportuno
frenare energicamente ogni volta che si
incrocia un altro concerto così andate a
slittare finite direttamente nei cartoni
di bugs bunny qualora il conducente pur
conducendo nel semaforo luce gialla
lampeggiante impone d'arresto sempre
prima dell'incrocio
no perché se sei già indirizzato verso
l'incrocio quindi se già praticamente
dentro
se poi ti fa poi è un casino quindi se
sei giorno fa in tempo a fermarti quindi
se l'hai già impegnato stai già
impegnando dovrebbe di che si che
diventi e gialla l'ormai vai perché se
non fai più casino che altro quindi
falso se l'hai già impegnata falso se
raffigurato posto prima di ricorso
obbliga proseguire dritto yeah phoenicia
trasversale continue figura indica il
tutto dopo occorre arrestarsi vero certo
stop storicamente sono il rocket league
non ti fermi per diminuire
l'inquinamento provoca dei vicoli non
bisogna accelerare bruscamente durante
le partenze vero almeno virtù 16 fast
and furious li puoi farlo il segnale è
raffigurato preannuncia un incrocio con
strada in minore importanza benissimo
perché questo qua e la strada principale
dove siete voi quindi quella che ha la
precedenza alle strade laterali che più
piccola non si era piegato per 6 posto
sui veicoli per lavori stradali fermi
poi lento movimento certo perché questo
qua quando c'è
come è successo qualcosa lo piazzi
dietro se tu guidi e cioè lo piazzi
dietro ai veicoli quelli per i lavori
stradali pc con domande ma anche ragazzi
il conducente che intende effettuare il
sorpasso ha l'obbligo di azionare il
segnale acustico che sarebbe è del
clacson
ovviamente falso questo prima di
scendere da veicoli in sosta e concedeva
assicurarsi di avere ha spento il motore
ebbe per far bene non solo lascia accesa
la macchina centro della strada è stata
di incoscienza e fa fatica a respirare
bisogna liberare subito il naso la bocca
la vittoria e sociali vero la consegna
di emergenza accorsi a a
non si può occupare per le manovre di
sorpasso questa non la so no raga questa
non la so giuro comunque io direi vero
aperte che la corsia d'emergenza non è
sempre sulla destra quindi non puoi
sorpassare a destra è una cazzata devi
sorpresa guinho falso e se è raffigurato
può essere posta protetta protezione gli
attraversamenti pedonali pericolosi
questo poi indica che tu hai la
precedenza quindi poi non c'entra niente
ragazzi lo fate tutte ci siamo è il
momento correggi
[Musica]
voi vi rendete conto che la mia vita è
questa c'è allora quanta quando youtube
è subentrato ho avuto un bel po di
bruciore culo ad avere sto lavorano
perché comunque un lavoro che mi piace
citare un po come se dio avesse
incanalato la sfiga in un altro c'è come
se avesse proprio incanalato la sfiga in
un altro un altro scompartimento nella
mia vita che la patente
però quello che voglio dire che io la
parola esame superato la ricevo da anni
ogni volta che vado a fare l'esame la
patente il giorno prima ne faccio mille
di questi sono tutti esame superato
esame superato esame superato e quando
vado a far la patente di bocciano cristo
di un dio io cosa devo fare io quando
sono lì che sto facendo l'esame mi
bocciano o c'è un coach è veramente
qualcuno che mette mano al database ogni
volta che faccio e mi mette sempre un
errore in più come semi punta perché non
è possibile non mi stupisce per niente
non sta risultando perché mi succede
sempre che succhia via proposto noi non
mi succede solo quando faccio la patente
questo sono questa è la mia vita
e a proposito organi dello stato
ministero della patente di christie
avete visto potete darmela l'ho fatto
davanti a voi l'ho fatto davanti a voi e
fatemeh arrivata a buca delle lettere
che bego stato pagato sette volte basta
basta
beh ragazzi questa è la video questa è
la mia non patente però l'esame lo
supero perché tanto chi cazzo te ne
frega ci vediamo al prossimo video e dai
ragazzi
[Musica]